[Applause]
please limited time we got a big show
just to save time
who here has not been groped by Donald
Trump pledges I mean this sir I wish I
could tell you how many women it is
we're making accusations but haven't
refreshed my server in 10 minutes I mean
my phone is blowing up it's a samsung
that's different but I mean you know
what there's a lot of things people
don't like about Hillary Clinton but
when she rubs you the wrong way it's
just an expression
okay this apparently Donald Trump is a
little handsy this is Halloween I got a
great costume I'm gonna glue a pair of
tiny orange hands to my tits and go as a
trump victim I think it's gonna be to
Rivet of course some of these
accusations of infidelity happened when
he was married to Milani which is very
sad Malati a poor sweet girl she has
locked herself in her packing crate and
booze
it's it's so sad but see the problem for
Donald Trump with all these accusers is
that there is a corroborating witness
Donald Trump you know it was only a week
ago right it seems like years ago it was
just one week ago with this news broke
Friday we loved it where Donald Trump
was on Billie Bush's party bus saying I
better use tic tacs in the case I start
kissing her this girl they were looking
at I don't wait he said when you're a
star you can do anything and grab their
[ __ ] and now he's outraged that women
have come forward how dare you claim I
did the things I claim I do
I mean at the debate Sunday did you see
the debate Sunday okay Anderson Cooper
was asking her this he said when he
tells people that he grabs woman's
[ __ ] it's not really true
I'm not really a rapist I just say that
when I want people to like me
come on people who are you gonna believe
me or me
some Republicans are in a bit of
disarray about this is a lot of finger
pointing going on people are saying I
told you we should have gone with Bill
Cosby but most of them are sticking with
Donald Trump why because the voters are
sticking with Donald Trump to the
Republican base out there this is not a
deal breaker
GOP now stands for grab our [ __ ]
and what about our dicks can we grab
dicks - it's that part of the Republican
platform also can I walk up to Mike
Pence cup his balls stick my hands up
his shirt and play with his nipples for
a while is that part of the platform
like the estate tax we believe in the
right of every American to feel up
strangers and also school vouchers you
know this is and this is not even the
worst of it because in my opinion by his
own admission Donald Trump said with the
cooperation of a lot of people that with
the Teen Miss USA the Teen Miss USA
pageant he used to walk in unannounced
into the girls dressing room if as if
models need another reason to throw up
and there's audio of Trump telling
Howard Stern that troubled teens
probably are great in bed there's a news
article about him talking to a 14-year
old girl and saying just think in a
couple of years I'll be dating you and
she's shot right back at a couple of
years I'll be voting for Hillary that's
good and then again with corroboration
from actual videotape Donald Trump on an
escalator a ten year old girl goes by
and he says I'll be dating her this is
apparently his line Republicans your
nominee for president has a pick-up line
for underage girls
ooh well that brought the proceedings to
a halt but what does Donald Trump say
about all this ridiculous I would never
cheat on my daughter
he says he was all on this dump
yesterday and today talking about how
this is a giant conspiracy a sinister
global power structure you know who's in
on everybody the media the bank's the
Clinton Foundation Carlos Slim he said
that the whole deal going on we're gonna
have to figure it out I always figure
things out yes
okay [ __ ] I could see him in Trump
Tower right now you know with one of
those walls with the newspaper stories
and the headshots drawing lines between
them with a red marker okay I'm an
[ __ ]
women hate [ __ ] women can vote it
doesn't add up